uhoh do you still not understand what
the word communism means so the most
commonly agreed on definition for
communism I think is a stateless
classless moneyless society where the
workers own the means of production a
utopian idea of Communism today is
victims of Communism day so this video
is dedicated to the millions of people
murdered at the hands of their own
government there's been a Resurgence of
Communism Lately from Street tags and
Soviet Flags to glittery gifts and high
fashion runways but these same people
who would rightfully denounce Hitler
Nazi Germany because it killed 6 million
Jews are embracing an ideology that
resulted in the deaths of 100 million
people not to mention poverty starvation
and oppression for Millions more and
it's wild to see women advocate for
communism which was definitely not great
for them either communist countries were
led by men divorced people were
ostracized it was practically impossible
to find birth control and state-run
grocery stores meant long lines to feed
your family assuming they even had food
communism wasn't cute cool or
compassionate no matter what your
favorite influencer says Communism is a
failed ideology that rules only through
the use of force which is why it should
never ever be tried again